hi I'm Kyra hi I'm Stephanie its Britt
and it's Jason
whatup cheese bags I'm Kevin I'm Jackie
and today we're doing something
mysterious that we don't know about
which is kind of the point of the show
today you'll be drawing each other as
Avengers okay why alright let's jump
right into it okay which one do you want
to be okay I want to say I want to be an
Iron Man and oh there are so many women
in design it however you want be as free
as you want to be Nathan that's so fun
that's if you can be war machine you're
just wrong as war machine who do you
want to be just make me dr. strange
doctor a little weird alright so the
hand stuff yeah the hand what avenger do
you want to be I would have a lot of fun
as Valkyrie my thor ragnarok at a test
of thompson version I think she's really
badass okay so which avenger do you want
to be me oh I want to be Thanos of
course you do
I want to be fan of yeah I want big
losses and I want a big chin yep who do
you want to be surprised me really you
get to choose Jackie I get to chose who
you're gonna draw me as oh it's gonna be
it looks like we're allowed to use
reference on this one yeah thank God I
don't want to imagine an Iron Man suit
for my head I already hate decisions I
mean you just started I know I am like
already in panic mode and I started now
so why did you choose him big it's gonna
be something that's gonna amuse you I
know that yeah it's gonna be something
that you find very funny no I'm having
like issues drawing
what would you like me to do Jason you
can I take a picture of home are you
looking this way slightly give me a
smile it's like a dream both smile yeah
thank you that's perfect that's creepy
thank you Jason is working from a photo
cheating shouldn't artists not have to
use reference ever and just come up with
everything from their head all the time
hey I used photo reference constantly no
using reference is not cheating using
references really that's an important
element of doing art people that think
that using reference is copying I think
they don't understand what goes on in
the art world
that's my spicy take on that will be a
dream
Ironman colors oh yeah I want to be
green black and yellow green black and
gold green because those this is
Jamaican colors Oh flag I don't remember
this character wearing this outfit but I
guess he did wear it he so it's a he
okay no I'm not gonna guess okay but
like most of the characters in this
universe or of man fair enough
maybe you should check my first think
about that what no you're making coffee
what that's my I have the powers of the
universe at my disposal and I use them
to heat up my coffee yeah cool
Jackie how you doing this is pretty
interesting it's not like a super good
drawing okay but I think you're gonna
like it I think you're gonna like who I
chose for you but I think you're gonna
roast me oh no I'm not and you're gonna
be learned you look great right now
I do know Oh what superpower would you
want to have a super the superpower I
feel like I'd want to have would be
probably like the ability to transform
into anything cuz you can do like
anything yeah really unstoppable I've
always liked the idea of flying
I feel like real world physics would
probably make that
not great to do yeah I feel like there's
a lot of powers that seem cool but
they're probably like mm-hmm the one
that always gets me is like reading
minds you're like that's that's the last
power I know it's like too much it's
like would you really want to know that
if you could be any one of the Avengers
besides Thanos who would you pick who
has the least bad life maybe vision no
vision like mega dies he like gets his
like four head ripped off but he like
lives forever cuz he's a robot yeah but
his forehead gets ripped off also he's a
robot doesn't he struggle with emotions
don't you struggle with emotions
[Music]
so how do you think you're doing I don't
have the Hulk attitude you're not the
angry version of hope I'm realizing now
that I'm missing that component I'm
gonna make you angry
I'm gonna give you angry eyebrows oh boy
are you having a terrible time I'm not
having a terrible time it's just this
you look very squat squat yeah
you're making me squat happen you have
no neck come on well the neck look
you're right do you ever like okay when
you draw our hands I always have to like
count the fingers a couple times yeah I
kept Maul he's like missing fingers
that's four fingers that's good good
that's the right amount one thing I'm
always paranoid about is drawing
backwards hands oh me too I was just
thinking about right I'll give you a
hint this is an artistically inclined
Iron Man yeah I'll take it
abs are hard oh yeah abs are really hard
to draw so strong I want to intimidate
everything it's always hard when they
have like very complicated visual
effects to their power set you know this
is like how do you draw oh you have a
like green sparkly things yeah so his
whole thing was like if half the world
is gone we have more resources yeah my
coworker said the funniest thing to me
okay she said why instead of making half
the world disappeared did she not just
make everyone 50% small good points real
good was the idea of that was so funny
and anticlimactic if he used his powers
and snapped and everyone just got a
little smaller like not to smell like
just small enough that it's inconvenient
exactly like oh now cars are too big and
everything we've ever invented it's a
little too big I like this I think it's
a good plan
you look like a frog did you look like a
frog you love frogs it says I got the
feet that makes very froggy I have
finished I'm almost done
stick with me kid I can floss can I show
them that I can floss guys look I know
how to floss
[Music]
congratulations Jenny you are the
coolest kid of 2018 that's 2020 oh I see
now very much it isn't had to do buddy I
think I did okay I'm just wondering if
it looks like you because your eyes are
kind of closed in this mm-hmm
you have kind of a Doctor Strange
haircut without the gray something like
I hope it like reads as you it's it's
not quite Hulk enough but it's mostly
green lady who kind of looks like a frog
that's exactly what I want to be so I'm
glad that looks like I'm really glad
that I could fulfill that dream for you
I think you're gonna like it I think it
actually is a pretty good drawing okay
it's like horrible like subject wise but
you know I think it's cool does it look
like me this is sick I've never looked
cooler Jason oh yeah like super soakers
have lepen oh my god like this is such a
good drawing it looks so cool beautiful
I wish I looks like that just like my
ultimate form oh my god do you like it
this is great I love this thing did you
choose this character because I have
gray hair no did you make him gray
because no the raccoon is gray okay but
I chose him because I was thinking like
all the weirdest characters I confuse
you with he was like a raccoon
rude no this is great I love it and what
do you think this is really present yeah
it's giving me like secondhand like
itches it looks good
I'm glad you made me look tough I look
like a off-brand garden gnome that you
could find in Marshall's discount rec so
if you had Thanos's glove and you did
the snap do you think I would survive
that's find out ha joke's on you wait
Jackie I don't feel so good
see you later cheese bag
[Music]